لا أعرف إلى أي مدى يحب هذا المعجب
أديل
كثيرًا لدرجة أنه بدا وكأنه في حالة نشوة ناجمة عن
أديل وهو يسجل نفسه
باستخدام عصا سيلفي، لكن إحدى
حفلات المغنية الأخيرة في لاس فيغاس تعرضت
للحرق بلطف لأنها وقفت تحجب
رؤية الآخرين و  ثم بعد ثانيتين
من ضحكها
[تصفيق]
حتى أديل لاحظت من على المسرح أن
الأمن حاول بهدوء إقناعه
بالتخفيف من حدة الأمر، أوقفت أديل العرض [
موسيقى] أنقذتها
إلهته
حتى الأمن بدا غير آمن عندما
حذرته أديل ماذا تفعلين
لماذا تضايقه، هل يمكنك
تركه بمفرده، من فضلك، ليس عليك
الجلوس، أنت بخير، ابق هنا،
بعض المعلقين عبر الإنترنت كانوا منزعجين منه
واعتقدت أديل أن الأمر على ما يرام ولكني
متأكد من الأشخاص الذين دفعوا الكثير  من المال
أن تجلس خلفه وتحدق في الجزء الخلفي
من رأسه وهو غاضب بشكل أكثر إيجازًا،
أنت لست مميزًا فقط اجلس F لأسفل
لكنه لم يكن جالسًا أشكرك شكرًا
لك عندما نشر مقطعًا على Tick Tock
المعجب المجهول  كتب إلى أديل أنك
بدأت تتحدث معي
وتوقفت حرفيًا عن التنفس، يده ترتعش بشكل واضح وهو
يتناول مشروبًا، استمتع
بالعرض،
اتركه وشأنه عندما تتوقف أديل عن الغناء
حتى يغير الأمن نغمتها
[تصفيق]
سي إن إن
نيويورك